la guerra casi cuerpo a cuerpo
en este vídeo poco frecuente de los
enfrentamientos directos en ucrania
aparecen soldados chechenos que no
luchan con rusia sino en su contra
aliados ucrania se declaran anti putin y
lanzan misiles a una veintena de
kilómetros de kiev
transcurrido un mes desde el comienzo de
la ofensiva es esta resistencia
implacable la que ha ralentizado los
ataques rusos en los primeros días de
conflicto estas imágenes de un
impresionante convoy militar ruso de 60
kilómetros de largo hacían pensar que la
planeadora rusa sería imparable pero la
defensa ucraniana militares y civiles
les organizaron los planes de moscú
incluso algunas ciudades
mayoritariamente rusas como ésta gerson
se oponen al invasor no los invitamos
grita esta mujer a varios soldados desde
el 24 de febrero los rusos avanzan pero
cada vez más lento y no han alcanzado
kiev según múltiples expertos ya no
tienen los recursos para invadir todo el
país por donde se extiende una gran
oposición pequeños los ucranianos están
bien informados se benefician de
información de una parte de
estadounidense y otra de la otan que les
permite reaccionar saber dónde está el
enemigo y atacar con precisión por eso
creo que cuatro o cinco generales rusos
murieron pero los rusos siguen en
posición de fuerza con estos nuevos
misiles hipersónicos más rápidos y
precisos y con todo un plan de batalla
reestructurado sobre ciertos sitios
estratégicos como mariupol una ciudad
devastada por los ataques que alcanzaron
a civiles y también un hospital de
maternidad para imponerse las
negociaciones rusia quiere infligir el
máximo de bajas humanas y daños
materiales a ucrania un pulso que
incluye siempre la amenaza de armas
químicas o nucleares